we do in this series going gray I'm back
to the groove back to default about my
most important thing computing or one of
the most important things ultimately
bollocks yeah I think so so maybe it's
not the most important but it certainly
one of the most interesting in one that
one of the weirdest ideas in computer
science and that is the Y Combinator the
background to this is that in the last
video we did an introduction to the
lambda calculus and this generated quite
a lot of discussion and comments which
was very nice but it turned out that the
top comment was can we have more on the
Y Combinator so that's what we're going
to do today so what the Y Combinator
actually is is a way of doing recursion
in a language which doesn't have any
recursion or any looping mechanism at
all so what would start off with is a
quick refresher about what recursion
actually is so recursion is the idea of
defining things in terms of themselves
and a simple example of this is the
well-known factorial function so let's
let's have a little look at this the way
factorial works is you give it a number
like 3 and it's going to count down from
3 to 1 and multiply up all the numbers
in between so for example factorial of 3
then would be 3 times 2 times 1 which
would give us the result 6 and then we
can think how do we actually define this
function and it turns out that the
factorial function has a very simple and
a very natural definition using
recursion defining things in terms of
itself so let's see how we can do that
if you give the factorial function a
number n it's going to make a choice
between doing one of two things if the
number you give it is already 1 which is
the point where you're trying to count
down to then there's nothing to do so if
the number equals 1 then we just return
the result 1 otherwise what we're going
to do is we'll take the number you're
given and we'll multiply it by the
factorial of its predecessor so for
example if n was 3 we would take 3 times
the factorial of 2 so this is a
recursive function because we're
defining factorial in terms of itself
the factorial of any number n is defined
in terms of the factorial of n minus 1
so you can see the way that this is
going to work if you give it a number
like 3 it's going to loop round
two one and so on until it eventually
gets to one and then it will stop and do
all the multiplies let's do a little
example of this running to see that we
know how it actually works if we take
factorial of 3 so factorial of any
number that's not 1 is going to be that
number times the factorial of its
predecessor
so we'll take 3 times the factorial of 2
and then what do we do now well we just
do the same thing again we've worked out
what factorial of 3 is now we need to
work out what factorial of 2 is and we
just run the definition again
recursively so we copy down what we had
before we have 3 times and then we have
2 times factorial of 1 and then the
final step is the base case this is
where the recursion stops because the
factorial of 1 according to our
definition was just 1 so we're going to
get 3 times 2 times 1 which is 6 so
that's a simple example of a recursive
function and how it may run so what
we're looking at in the last video was
the lambda calculus which is a minimal
language for defining functions and it's
only got three things in it it's got
variables like X Y and said it's got a
way of building functions that's the
lambda notation that we saw last day and
it's got a way of applying functions
that's just putting two things next to
each other and everything else in the
lambda calculus is encoded in terms of
these three basic things so an example
which we did last day was the logical
values true and false and I'll just
refresh your memory about how we did
this last day the two logical values are
true and false and how do you represent
these or encode these in the lambda
calculus you do it very simply as two
functions so true is going to be encoded
as the function that takes two things x
and y and just gives you back the first
one x and then false is the opposite it
takes two things x and y and it gives
you back the second one and these in
codings can then be used to define any
other function which you'd like on the
logical values like i think last day we
looked at naught and we look to and and
we looked at or so any other function
can be defined in terms of these two
encodings these encodings are very
natural the
express the idea that in programming
true and false are often used to choose
between two different things so if one
thing is true you do do something and if
it's false then you do something else
and these two definitions using code
this idea of choosing between one thing
or another thing what we're thinking
about today is recursion and you can ask
yourself if we have our definition like
the factorial function here the key
thing in the definition is that it's
recursive we're defining the factorial
function in terms of itself recursively
so how do we encode recursion in the
lambda calculus which doesn't have any
sophisticated feature like that at all
so let's start off by reducing the
problem a bit let me write down the very
simplest recursive definition which I
can think of and the simplest possible
recursive definition it's just a program
that loops it doesn't do anything at all
so here would be the program so I just
say loop equals loop and if you think
about running this thing we say what's
the value of loop or how do you execute
loop well you just go to the right hand
side and you say well it's loop so you
go back to the left hand side and it's
just going to go around like this
forever it's just going to kind of spin
on the spot without doing anything at
all so this is the simplest recursive
program which you could write down so
how could I encode this behavior in the
lambda calculus and the key to this is
something called self application the
idea of applying something to itself or
in this case applying a function to
itself so let me show you how to encode
loop so the way this works is will
define loop to be this function here so
the first thing to observe is that we
have two functions in here and in fact
two copies of the same function we look
at this function here and this function
here they're both exactly the same so
what we're doing here is we're applying
this function to itself it's the idea of
self application and this actually
occurs at another level as well if we
look at what each of these functions
actually does it takes an input called X
and then applies X to itself so again
this is the idea of self application
we're taking something in here and then
we're applying it to itself and the same
was happening over here
and it turns out that this idea of self
application is the key to how you do
looping or recursion
in a language which doesn't have support
for that feature so let's actually check
that this thing actually has the
behavior that we'd like check that our
actually performance looping if we write
down the same thing again we have lambda
X X X and then we have lambda X xx let's
think about how we can actually run this
thing so we need to remember what a
function actually does so a function
takes an input like X and then it tells
you what to do with it
so in this case it takes an X and just
makes two copies of it side by side and
in this case the X is this thing here
this is the argument or the input to the
function we're applying it to itself so
what's going to happen is that this
input is going to be plugged in or
substituted for X and then we'll just
get two copies of the thing in the box
so that's how you would run the function
so if we write this down we're going to
get two copies of the box and inside the
box will be exactly the same thing and
what you see here is that in going from
here to here we've got exactly back to
where we started we started with this
expression here which was the definition
of loop and we've ended up with exactly
the same thing and of course if we do
the same thing again if we say this is a
function this is its input let's plug it
in in the two places where we see X then
we'll get exactly the same thing again
so this thing is just going to go around
in circles it will never guess anywhere
every time you run one step of it it
will go back to exactly the same point
so it encodes the idea of looping so
that's a simple example let's have a
more general example of recursion so
here's a little recursive definition I'm
going to define a function called rec
four recursion and it's going to take
another function as an input and what
it's going to do is apply that function
to rec of s so what does this definition
actually do well first of all we can see
that it's recursive because rec of F is
defined in terms of rec of F but it's
not just looping around all the time
it's got a function f here sitting in
the way so we think about unwinding this
definition what you'll get is F of F of
F of F forever if you run this recursive
program it's just going to apply the
function f infinitely often and this
turns out to be the idea of what's
called general recursion in computers
this is the most general pattern of
recursion you can have and any other
recursive function can be encoded in
terms of this one so if we can encode
rec in the lambda calculus we can encode
any recursive function but let me set
you a couple of exercises at this point
using the definition of rack which is
recursive how do you program the define
or redefine loop to be rec of some
function so you've got to figure out
what function to apply rec to here it's
actually a very very simple function
it's probably the simplest or it is the
simplest function you could write down
in the lambda calculus so don't try and
over complicate it right down the
simplest function you can here work
through the definition of rec and you'll
see that it actually has the looping
behavior a slightly more interesting
exercise a bit more challenging is how
to define the factorial function using
rec and I'll give you a bit of a hint on
this one what you need to do is pass it
lambda f lambda N and then you need to
figure out what you write for the
question mark here okay and what you'll
find is that the function that you write
in here is not recursive it's the non
recursive part of the factorial function
okay so that's a bit of a challenging
exercise this one's quite easy
this one's a little bit more challenging
but you'll learn a lot about the way
recursion works in the lambda calculus
if you do these two exercises so what
we've reached now is the point where if
we can encode rec which is general
recursion any other recursive function
can be encoded in terms of that or
defined in terms of that if we can
encode rec then we're done
because that lets us do everything so
it's a bit of a mouthful so I haven't
tried to remember eyes that I've just
got a copy pre-prepared here here is the
definition or one possible definition of
rec in the lambda calculus and this is
what's known as the Y Combinator and if
you look at this I mean it looks like a
jumble of symbols but it's actually very
similar to loop if we look back to see
the definition of loop it had the idea
of self-application so we applied a
function to itself and the function we
applied was lambda X xx and we saw how
when you run that it will actually
achieve the looping behavior if you look
at the definition of the Y Combinator
which is defined here it's got exactly
the same structure here we have a fun
and here we have another copy of the
same function so it's exactly the same
idea of self-application the only
difference here we haven't got lambda X
xx we've got an F in the way and that's
the S which is we're going to be kind of
repeatedly applying when we do the
recursion so this is the Y Combinator
it's not recursive but it encodes
recursion and this is a very simple but
powerful idea and you can do this in
most programming languages unless you
have some kind of pipe system which
would stop you from doing this this
gives you a way of doing recursion in a
language which doesn't have any
recursion at all if you want to know
where it comes from what was invented by
a mathematician from the United States
Haskell curry and this is the Haskell
who gives these name to the Haskell
programming language so if anyone asked
you about the Y Combinator this is what
it is if you want to know a bit more
about the Y Combinator and you can of
course look online and there's a very
nice Wikipedia page about this where you
can find more details about these kind
of things and see how to do some of the
calculations and proofs of some of the
things which have been saying but
actually it's interesting that the top
hit on Google for Y Combinator is not
this stuff it's actually a company which
is called Y Combinator you think well
why would anyone call our company Y
Combinator if you look at the company's
web page they've got a frequently asked
questions list and one of the questions
is why did you choose the name Y
Combinator for your company and they say
a number of things here so Y Combinator
is one of the coolest ideas in computer
science and of course I'm going to agree
with this I think this is a very very
nice very interesting fundamental idea
about how you do recursion in a language
which doesn't have recursion and it's
also a metaphor for what this company
does so the Y Combinator
is a way of having programs that run
other programs and in this case it's a
way of doing recursion in a language
which doesn't have recursion and that's
basically what their company is doing
they're a company that helped start
companies they're a startup incubator in
Silicon Valley and it's the same kind of
self-application idea they want they
want to help someone do to make a
company and it's the same thing here we
want to have programs that run other
programs so for me this is certainly one
of the coolest ideas in computer science
this
is Alonzo Church who was a mathematician
at Princeton University in the United
States and he was the person who
invented the lambda calculus and what he
was interested in is what is the notion
of a funk